what up guys goes in here for anime
uproar and today we're going to be talk
about the real reason Zeke actually
betrayed his parents if you want to see
more attack on titan on this channel let
me know by giving that like button a
colossal smash if you haven't be sure to
subscribe and hit that notification bell
so you don't miss any new videos as
always there will be manga spoilers
you've been warned okay so let's review
what happened in episode 57 of the
attack on Titan anime we find out that
Grisha was from an internment Zone in
the nation of Marlay the Marlins
discriminate against ldiots a kid Grisha
goes beyond the walls of the internment
Zone one day so he can show his little
sister an airship however they get
caught he gets physical punishment and
she gets killed he really starts to hate
Marley after that eventually he joins
the LD and restorationist a group who
wants to overthrow Marley and rule and
restore the LD n Empire through this
organization he meets Deena Fritz Dean
has a royal blood Adele DN a member of
the group that stayed on the continent
when the 145th King went to the island
of parody and built the three walls
together Deena and Grisha have a son
called Zeke as it turns out Zeke is in
fact Aaron's half-brother and grows up
to be the current user of the Beast
Titan when the marlane government
decides to gather warriors from the
subjects of the Ameer Grisha offers his
son Zeke he wants Zeke to pledge
allegiance to Marley while acting as a
double agent and secretly helping the
LDN people however around the time Zeke
turned seven he betrayed his parents to
Marlon government along with the rest of
the LD and restorationist so little Zeke
sent his parents and all the
restorationist to the Isla de Paradis
where LD ins are turned into mindless
Titans the big question is why did seek
betray his parents in the anime Grisha
explains that he saw Zeke as a child of
royal blood and as the hope of restoring
el dia but he wonders if he ever thought
of him as his son Grisha says that Zeke
chose to protect himself and his
grandparents in exchange for turning in
his foolish parents to Marley public
security after I read this part in the
attack on Titan manga I was sure that it
wasn't as simple as it looked at first
glance in the attack on titan guidebook
Zeke or rather the
titans cordon off the charts 11 out of
10 and intelligence the only other
character to score that high in
intelligence was the mad genius han Jie
so even then I assumed that even though
he was only 7 there was more behind
Zeke's decision than Grishin you if it
was anyone else it might be assumed that
Marley was able to brainwash such a
young child into being a loyal warrior
after all even at 12 years old Gabi was
still completely brainwashed by Marley
and propaganda
however with someone as smart as eek
that didn't seem likely to be the case
we had to wait quite a long time but
recently in the manga we did finally get
Zeke side of the story and as I expected
it wasn't as simple as it seemed at
first glance from grisha's perspective
from Zeke's memories we get much more
information about his childhood while
grisha's account glossed over it pretty
quickly grisha's perspective gave us no
real insight into what kid's ich was
actually thinking and how those thoughts
were formed Zeke's flashback reveals
that he was constantly being
discriminated against for being LD and
he was also deeply affected by that
discrimination as a kid he was brought
to tears when a janitor threw water at
him and his family claiming his job was
to rid the place of Filth
even though Grisha his wife and his son
had permission to be there they were
still treated horribly because they were
ldiots the jailer insulted them and said
it was only natural for their kind to be
exterminated Grisha put a lot of
pressure on Zeke throughout his
childhood he told Zeke that he would be
the one to save everyone
he put the fate of aldia and the LD and
restorationist on a little kid after
Grisha enrolled Zeke into the program
Zeke struggled he lagged behind the
other kids
unlike Grisha he wasn't passionately
driven to restore aldia in fact at one
point in the manga Zeke asks his parents
to stop he tells them to not do anything
dangerous anymore he says if the
government finds out about them they'll
send them all to Paradis Island where
they'll all be turned into Titans so
picture this a little kid just wanting
his parents to stop doing something that
could get them all killed or worse
Zeke implies that he doesn't want to end
up like aunt Fay who was brutally
murdered by Captain gross he probably
hopes that his parents don't want to see
him die he hopes they care about his
safety he
probably wants to hear that but instead
grisha yells at him and slams the table
Grishka makes a frightened Zeke start to
cry but decrying Zeke still goes on
trying to convince his parents he
believes like grisha's dad does that if
they don't break any rules like Grisha
did when he took they outside the walls
then they would all be safe
he clearly disagrees with his father who
is willing to risk everything including
his son's life to take down Marley and
restore el dia despite the fact that
Zeke disagrees with Grisha
he continues to follow the wishes of his
parents he follows them even as his
parents constantly ignore him put
increasing pressure on him abandon him
to the Marlon government program against
his wishes and more well Zeke and I kick
Grisha to treat him like a son at all
only like a tool for el Diaz restoration
he meets Tong saver in the warrior
program tom is the possessor of the B
Stein power and he develops a close
relationship with Zeke they play cash
together talk and bond Tom who lost the
son of his own values Zeke for who he is
he doesn't use him as a tool he's kind
to him he plays catch with him he talks
to him and he cares about him in short
he is a better father to him than Grisha
ever was while Grisha is willing to risk
Zeke's life Tom is heartbroken at the
thought of Zeke dying or being turned
into a Titan but more on that later
let's turn to the immediate events that
led Zeke to eventually betray his
parents as Zeke is on mopping Duty one
day he overhears Marlena officers
talking about the LD and restorationist
he figures out that the Marlins already
know a lot about the LD and
restorationist and it's only a matter of
time before they all get captured after
hearing this Z can't help but cry
Tom shows up and starts to question Zeke
and figures out what's going on after
all his parents did to him
Zeke still never thinks of turning them
in to save himself he has resigned
himself to his fate he thanks Tom for
playing catch with him he tells Tom that
even if he becomes a Titan he will be
sure to remember him it is at this point
that Tom who is in pain even thinking
about Zeke's cruel fate tries to
convince him to accuse his parents tom
was a completely different kind of
father he loved his wife and son they
were his purpose of
life but when his wife found out he was
LD in she killed herself and his son it
was only then that Tom joined the Marlin
military he was so devastated when he
lost his son that he just wanted to kill
himself in the grandest way possible
coming from this background Tom sees
Zeke's parents as awful people who not
only took their living son for granted
but willingly put him in mortal danger
as well keep in mind tom is one of the
only people that ever cared about Zeke
as a person and actually treated him
like Zeke and not like some tool for
revolution perhaps the only other people
to do that where Zeke's grandparents who
showed concern for their grandson tom
tells Zeke that accusing his parents is
his only option if he shows his loyalty
to Marley by going to the authorities
and accusing them he can save himself
and his grandparents who were adamantly
against breaking the rules and always
cared about Zeke
even then Zeke says he could never do
that but Tom keeps going he lays it all
out for him he tells him that his
parents have been awful to him they used
him for the sake of their reckless plan
they put him a seven-year-old boy and
his grandparents in mortal danger
they put expectations on him gave up on
him all for their own reasons and they
never showed the slightest bit of
concern for him
finally he tells Zeke they never loved
him this is what seems to finally
convince Zeke to go through with
accusing his parents it is the fact that
he didn't get love from his parents that
helped him go through with his choice
while he got love from his grandparents
and even Tom his parents just used him
as a tool so he ends up accusing them so
he can save his grandparents make Tom
happy and maintain his own image of a
loyal Marley and warrior at the same
time we know that he's not a brainwashed
Marlon warrior because he later promises
Tom that he will inherit the beast Titan
but not for Marley's sake he has decided
to retake the founding Titan steal it
from Marley and save the world
he decides that he will use the founding
Titan power to make it so Aldean's can't
have children and in that way he plans
to free the people of the world from the
fear of titans and 3ld ends from there
suffering Zeke very much agrees with Tom
who believes that it would have been
better not to have been born in LD and
at all because it resulted in so much
suffering in the end tom is the real
reason Zeke accused his parents
we actually got a glimpse of him in
episode 57 but it will be awhile before
the anime explains his significance
however manga readers know that it was
he who convinced an unwilling Zeke to
betray his parents although you could
make the argument that Zeke's parents
betrayed him first Tom was only able to
convince Zeke to accuse his parents
because of the way his parents treated
him they used him as a tool to
accomplish their own goals while paying
little or no attention to Zeke's
feelings and safety because they were so
distant and unloving his parents created
an emotional vacuum within Zeke and when
someone like Tom came around who took
the time to bond with Zeke it was
inevitable that he would secure a
special place in Zeke's heart it's not
surprising that Zeke respected Tom's
opinion more than grisha's because Tom
acted like more of a father to Zeke than
Grisha ever did and he respected Zeke's
own feelings more than Grisha ever did
so that is the true story behind Zeke's
betrayal
Zeke knew his parents were going to get
caught anyway it was only a matter of
time when they were caught the whole
family would be punished
still Zeke was prepared to face that
punishment despite how poorly his
parents treated him but eventually Tom
succeeded in convincing him to accuse
his parents by pointing out that they
never loved him
thus Zeke saved himself and his
grandparents and maintained his image as
a loyal Marlon so he could eventually
carry out his final plan although it did
seem like he betrayed his parents it was
only a matter of time before they were
caught anyways so it's not like his
accusation changed their fate it just
sped it up let me know what you think in
the comments should a seven year old
Zeke be blamed for betraying his parents
I personally don't think so his parents
forced him to do things he didn't want
to do never paid attention to his wishes
or feelings and even then it took Tom a
father figure to convince the young Zeke
to save himself and his grandparents by
accusing his already doomed parent
so I wouldn't blame Zeke for his actions
in this case but I do blame him for
attempting to carry out his final plan
just as Grisha tried to force his view
of the world on Zeke Zeke is trying to
force his view of the world on every LDN
just as Grishka let Zeke's choose his
own path
Zeke should let every LDN decide their
own path and not decide for them if
they're going to die an early death or
not have kids but that's just my opinion
I welcome your thoughts and that is it
for today's video thank you so much for
watching if you enjoy this video make
sure to go beast mode on that like
button to let me know if you haven't be
sure to subscribe and bring that
notification bell so you get notified
when future attack on time videos drop
we've been uploading a lot of attack on
Titan videos recently and we have a lot
more on the way don't forget to let me
know what other attack on Titan videos
you would like to see in the comments a
big thank you goes out to our patrons
over on patreon who helped make videos
like this one possible I especially want
to thank our pro tier patrons the one
and only Gilgamesh chubs is the man and
nothing but a fan and are the one tier
patrons the ones who stand atop all
clans baby Rey a seventeen FF DP Steven
and Radha a Lola not a Mattie Mac 239
and Michael Calderon if you enjoy our
work and get value from it you can
support more of it by going over to
patreon calm anim uproar and becoming a
patron today for as little as $1 if you
do so you'll get your name featured in
future videos alongside these amazing
people right here and you'll even get
access to our private patron only
discord so check out page on comm slash
anime uproar link in the description if
you're interested anyways thanks again
for all your support and until next time
see you space cowboys
[Music]
you
[Music]